I always made it a point that I didn't
want things on my knuckles I didn't want
them on my hands I didn't want them on
my neck I didn't want them on my face do
I judge people when they have them no
but do I want them for me no I also
think that this is very neurosciency
that we have dedicated brain areas
called fusiform gyrus is dedicated to
the processing of faces even if I just
put two dots and a line in between them
on a piece of paper you see that as a
face when one puts a tattoo on their
throat or on their face it actually
changes the way that the face is
perceived almost looks like another
mouth there can be a little bit jarring
it kind of competes with the processing
of their face in its normal way but look
when it comes down to it people need to
be individuals and live their life the
way they want to live their life I don't
care as long as people are living in
their best life and they're not harming
anybody I'm like great go for it I would
just think people should be thoughtful
about what they want to accomplish in
life in terms of a life mission and just
ask whether or not some of the permanent
cosmetic changes they might make might
align with compete with or be neutral
for those life missions